جدل متكرر تشهده الدول الاسلاميه في اواخر
شهر رمضان حول موعد اعلان عيد الفطر قبل
ان يبزغ هلال شوال ويحسم الجدل فلكيون
قالوا ان هلال شهر شوال يولد في صباح
اليوم الاخير من رمضان وهو الشرط الاول
لاعلان شهر قمري جديد في اليوم التالي
هؤلاء الفلكيون رجعوا ايضا ان تتمكن
العديد من الدول الاسلاميه من رؤيه الهلال
مساء اليوم لانه سيبقى في السماء مده
تقارب نصف الساعه بعد غروب الشمس وهو شرط
الثاني للتثبت من بدايه شوال وعليه ستعلن
تلك الدول يوم الجمعه اول ايام عيد الفطر
فلكيون اخرون شككوا بامكانيه رؤيه الهلال
مساء اليوم الخميس اخذينا بالاعتبار
الكسوف الكلي الذي حدث صباح اليوم وهي
ظاهره قد تؤثر على سهوله رصده هلال العيد
[موسيقى]